Nico has had a bizarre few days on
Thursday it seemed like he was out of G2
leaving his family and team behind to
collect the Saud bag on Falcons but now
it's confirmed that he's staying on G2
and is actually the hero we should all
aspire to be so what the hell is going
on with
[Music]
Nico all right before we get into the
video I need to let you all know that we
at the score Esports have a second merch
drop here's me to tell you all about it
guess what folks our touch grass hoodies
did so well that the suits are actually
letting us make even more dumb gamer
inspired like our new Bader zipup
hoodies made for all the real blue
collar workers out there perfect for any
environment whether it's catching fish
hanging your teammates out to dry or
just tugging on your or how about our
inspiring you onward and forward te the
ideal shirt for the sweatiest of Gamers
so that you can slam the W key with zero
resistance and little to no chafing
teammates don't like it them ruin
everyone's night oh and yeah we got
these blue Esports te's I forgot we made
these uh yeah they're definitely blue
and they say Esports game in style and
comfort with the score Esports drop two
available now okay so just last week I
did a video talking about all the news
that's been surrounding Mony and Saudi
team Falcons Falcons a team with endless
cash flow and one looking to make a
super team had the 18-year-old oper in
their crosshairs but g2's GM made it
clear in an interview that he was in
fact not for sale however I also noted
in that video that the same strong
language wasn't used to protect their
other star Nico and like 5 minutes after
we released that video CS journalist
Nell reported that Nico would in fact be
leaving to join Falcons and the News was
both shocking and not so shocking on one
hand Nico was leaving the team that he
helped build the team he was supposed to
win a major on the team that his own
flesh and blood literally plays on but
but at the same time accepting a deal
from a team like Falcons is an
opportunity to collect a bag listen I'm
sure that Nico was doing just fine on G2
but probably nothing comparable to what
Falcons were offering him now some
people took to Twitter to judge him for
the move given Saudi Arabia's shoddy
ethical track record While others were
wondering if this meant that monesy was
going to follow him however none of that
seemed to actually matter as of
yesterday because it turns out that Nico
isn't actually going anywhere I'm really
proud of the boys proud of myself of how
we handled everything this event and uh
it's definitely something that's going
to stay and stick in uh in my heart for
a long
time you guys know I'm not leing
right yes in this cheeky video disguised
as a goodbye and his subsequent tweet
Nico made it clear that he was in fact
staying with G2 the response was
overwhelmingly positive given the
Temptations many praised Nico for
believing in his team's future and
choosing to stay with the g2 family over
a chat however others were pissed that
this even got reported on in the first
place with many calling out Nell
directly and while I do agree that
Esports reporting especially when it
pertains to roster moves has been a bit
shoddy as of late I don't really blame
Nell for this one obviously we can't
know for sure if Nell was just pulling
this all out of his ass or not but if we
take it at face value it seems like for
a period of time it was true Nico was
leaving G2 so what happened well as Nell
pointed out in his own defense this is
just the way she goes sometimes which is
true both traditional Sports and Esports
can be absolute cluster when it comes to
signings and transfers this isn't
anything new despite how things appear
on the outside teams aren't one big
happy family sure the mission is to
generally win games but players are
there to make as much money as possible
while teams would like to spend as
little as they can n said in his second
report that things were all but
confirmed between both parties but then
there was a quote unexpected change what
was that unexpected change well only the
the people that were in those rooms
probably know but I'm sure we can give a
pretty informed guess one that former
astralis star and current Twitter goat
bubski literally predicted before it
happened in a mid- October tweet bubski
said it would be interesting to see if
players would use a potential Falcons
contract to leverage more money from
their current teams and that could be
exactly what happened with Nico and
Falcons he essentially forced g2's hand
either give me a better contract or I
walk now it's also important to note
that in a very recent interview the
Falcon CEO claimed that Nico was the one
to approach them this has yet to be
verified but if true it lends Credence
to the idea that Nico was The Mastermind
behind all of this though the Falcons
chairman also said that they never
actually reached an agreement and Nico
did say to bubski on Twitter that his
assessment of the situation was
incorrect I'm happy to say that we've
been approached by by Nico first at the
beginning and uh that he want to
do uh his move uh and he's exploring his
options it's interesting to wonder which
which other players that also received a
Falcons offer are trying to do the exact
same thing that Nico might have with
their orgs but as bubski pointed out
it's a weird time because orgs are
currently trying to spend as little
money as possible but if more teams like
Falcons enter the fry how much are orgs
going to be willing to spend to keep
their teams from being cannibalized okay
so yes Nico is in fact staying on G2 and
Mony likely is as well but Falcons is
still trying to build a super team so
who's in their sights now well unlucky
for ANS it seems like they might be the
next team on the chopping block and it
will be interesting to see if they can
do anything about it but given
everything that's happened over the last
few days maybe we just let Falcons play
their first match and then we can
actually lock in who's on the team
someone brought up they said like are
you drinking a Coke in the morning and
so no I'm not but everyone El thinks I
am and when I was doing it today
upstairs cuz they have the ice upstairs
they're like they I know from their eyes
that they think it's a Coca-Cola but is
in fact a coffee it's a tall Americano
if you
will